let's talk about the power of story and
how to tell a great one sure this is
what I just spoke about about a year of
a year ago well year ago too but a few a
few hours ago that's what you did okay
great what I spoke about which is what's
the power of story why why stories are
so important in our lives while we crave
them so much and once you understand the
power and purpose the purpose of a story
then you can write to that purpose and I
think the stories that really resonate
with audiences are stories that are that
are right on purpose as opposed to
something like if you're thinking well I
just want to entertain I just want to
have a lot of set pieces and show great
things you've never seen before well
okay that might be entertaining but you
might be missing something that's really
important in other words the that story
that you're gonna be writing or filming
will be off purpose you know it's not
the purpose of a story and so audiences
will walk away with kind of like yeah
that was great but yeah you know they
won't really know they won't be able to
put you know their hand on it about why
I didn't really enjoy it or what I
didn't have I didn't really resonate and
that has to do with the purpose of a
story what is the purpose of a story
what is it meant to do and so I talked
about how stories I mean every culture
from the beginning of time has had
stories some cultures may not have have
created fire some stores some cultures I
may not have invented the wheel but
there's not a single culture in the
history of mankind that has never had
stories so stories are truly universal
every single culture has had stories and
why is that why they're the shape they
are why what we've been telling stories
up to today and still we probably will
be able to tell stories till the end of
time and that's because they are crucial
to our survival as a species without
stories you would not have survived
would not have evolved to where we are
today so I like to say that story is
going to teach us that you just how to
survive how to live how to be human how
to interact with each other how to
change and deal with problems in the
world and stories that don't do that
fail
so that's my that's my spiel about
stories
you